ادعي لي في البدايه اقول ان روح صوتي من
كثر ما كان فيه هتافات وكان في همم تشجيع
للمنتخب المغربي قبل قليل ولكن نحن في سوق
واقف واليوم عاده يكون هاو يوم هادئ لا
هناك مباريات ولا ولا منافسات بين
المنتخبات ولكن كما تشاهدين الشباب من
المغرب في من العراق في من فلسطين
والشباب دائما متحمسون لهذه المباراه التي
ستجرى بعد يوم غد مع فرنسا او ضد فرنسا
وجميع في سوق واقف يتعرف على تاريخ هذا
الدرج يتعرف على تاريخ قطر
وفي
مشاريع هنا يرقص ويحتفل بالمنتخب المغربي
ولكن اذا اخذنا الصوره في مناطق مختلفه
نشاهد بعض الزوار الذين وصلوا الى هنا من
قطر من عمان من المناطق المختلفه وهم
يقومون طبعا بالتناول وجبات العشاء
والتمتع في هذه المنطقه اعتقد هنا الى
فلسطينيه
رائع رائع جدا جدا
يعني منتخب فرنسا ايقاع لسه مثل ما هو
المدرب ومثل ما هو العناصر مثل ما هو
تغيير بسيط بسيطتين الحارثي اللي رفع
الكاس نفس ماهو شكرا
والله فوز المغرب ما في شيء مستحيل
فازت على اسبانيا والبرتغال بقى فرنسا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]